we've lit the fuse on a population bomb
that will wipe out all of humanity there
is no tomorrow Mass starvation and
genocidal Wars over dwindling finite
resources the long prophecied Norse
Ragnarok the Abraham's last judgment the
nuk talang vaka the Hy trib's last day
if you're an attractive Charming
doomsday showman the end is near and if
you're a nerd whose best work solved the
problem of Airline overbooking things
have never been better because armagon
is not just mythological it's a battle
of science nature human behavior and two
men one a Goliath celebrated with
academic accolades and public popularity
the other a David relegated to relative
obscurity it's the story of a bet that
bound them together eternally a bet over
a handful of natural resources that
served as a proxy for our destiny the
lessons we learned from it have almost
been entirely ignored because they defy
every Instinct we have about how to
survive the foundational question of
their wager is more relevant now than
ever are we paradoxically killing
ourselves by existing and if the facts
say everything you think and feel is
wrong would you even care
the battle to feed all of humanity is
over in the 1970s and 1980s hundreds of
millions of people will starve to death
in spite of any crash programs embarked
upon now at this late date nothing can
prevent a substantial increase in the
world death rate in 1968 Paul erck
opened his doomsday prediction book the
population bomb with those three
sentences Erick was and still is an
entomologist his particular field of
study is butterflies and four years
before publishing a book that would
change the world he popularized a theory
of co-evolution the concept that natural
selection doesn't happen in isolation
and that plants and insects can have a
reciprocal relationship affecting both
their evolutionary pants he'd spent
decades thinking about how the world and
all the matter and life within its
ecosystem worked minerals water plants
animals humans and he concluded that it
did it or that it didn't anymore he saw
the end of the world as we know it and
he knew not only why it would happen but
he also knew how to stop it when he was
catching butterflies as a kid in 1930s
New Jersey his collection grew so large
that it filled his bedroom and he had to
sleep in a different room he had no idea
that his life was on a collision course
with a boy born in the same year living
just a few miles away Julian Simon's
interest was ultimately in economics and
the clash between Erick and Simon was a
decades long debate to decide the fate
of humanity and you it's a debate over
morals Mankind and math and nearly 200
years before the public wager between
Paul Erick and Julian Simon became the
most famous bet in history it started
with a political Economist whose
students affectionally referred to as
web toe Thomas malus focused on
economics and demography in his 1798 an
essay on the principle of population
malus wrote that it has been said that
the great question is now at issue
whether man shall henceforth start
forwards with accelerated velocity
toward illimitable and either to
unconceived Improvement or be condemned
to a Perpetual oscillation between
happiness and misery and after every
effort remains still at an immeasurable
distance from the wished for goal okay
his lifespan almost perfectly covered
the beginning and end of the Industrial
Revolution and he was at the center of
it in Great Britain it was an
unprecedented period of innovation For
the First Time Machine operated by a
growing Urban population wo textiles
which were then traded throughout a
global market of raw materials and
finished goods improvements in mining
and refining made Iron production sore
and after 100 years steam power had
finally matured life was getting better
fast but if you watched my video on
ignis semov viice and the disgusting
state of medicine in the early 1800s you
know that that it was also quickly
getting worse despite all these material
improvements and increases in overall
wealth human suffering seemed more
severe than at any point in history
poverty disease and strife ravaged the
lower classes of the England that
surrounded malus and the environment was
being degraded to the river temps had
been the lifeblood of the southeast of
England since before Julius Caesar's
Invasion and malus watched it turn into
a Cess pool in real time factories
dumped waste directly into the river
including Tannery chemicals and animal
parts from slaughter houses garbage was
also just thrown in because why not
it'll just wash away and it was the
perfect outlet for human sewage treating
the temps like a living dumpster and
infinite toilet killed Wildlife made
London stink and fueled chera outbreaks
that killed tens of thousand thousands
at a time and it really stunk July and
August of 1858 is known as the great
stink and Michael Faraday described the
temps as feculence rolled up in clouds
so dense that they were visible at the
surface the point is malus was
witnessing progress that even his
grandparents couldn't have fathomed and
he was also seeing misery social and
biological putri action and an obviously
unsustainable future he concluded that
the problem was people there were simply
too many of them to Fe he wrote it is an
obvious truth which has been taken
notice of by many writers that
population must always be kept down to
the level of the means of subsistence to
malus the math is what made the threat
of overpopulation so obvious and the Mal
Fusian catastrophe came down to
comparing exponential growth to linear
growth Malthus argued that the human
population left unchecked grows
exponentially because people like having
babies in the 1700s women of the lower
class tended to have about eight
children with maybe five of them
reaching adulthood if two parents
produce five kids and each of those
produce five more and each of those
produce five your family grows from 2 to
7 to 32 to
157 in just four generations that's an
increase of
7,750 in the human footprint and it was
an economical problem too the more
people the more available labor the more
labor the lower the wages and the lower
the wages the harder it is to get
increasingly expensive food that
everyone is competing over contrast that
with an increase in food production that
is not exponential according to malus
the available Farmland can only produce
so much food so people must starve by
the millions to restore the balance he
wrote subsistence increases only in an
arithmetical ratio and that was that in
the Battle of geometric versus
arithmetic progressions the geometric
side is going to win MTH is tried to
depict man as he really is inert
sluggish and averse from labor unless
compelled by necessity to him Humanity
was dumb and lazy especially the poor as
melus wrote The principle of population
England was the Pinnacle of modern
civilization but it was also in the wake
of having suffered through a costly
7even Years War the loss of its American
Empire and the dayby day threat of
instability and conflict from Napoleon
bonapart France if everything thing that
got better also made things worse in the
greatest country in the world why would
he have an optimistic outlook on the
rest of Humanity's future in
1971 Paul Erick agreed he said by the
year 2000 the United Kingdom will be
simply a small group of impoverished
Islands inhabited by some 70 million
hungry people I would take even money
that England will not exist exist in the
year 2000 in 1980 Julian Simon noticed
that England seemed to be doing just
fine and that what erck saw as a set of
problems destined to threaten the fate
of humanity were actually an incredible
opportunity the really interesting thing
about Julian Simon is that he started
out agreeing with Erick in the 1960s he
published articles arguing the
importance of Family Planning
encouraging people to limit birth on
economic grounds his path to economics
was circuitous he studied experimental
psychology at Harvard where he drove a
cab sold encyclopedias and played poker
to support himself he also worked in a
tin can factory a grass seed Factory and
a brewery so he knew Dirty Work and
manual labor and he knew the problems
with both after college he enlisted in
the Navy and spent time in some of the
less glamorous working ports of the
world where he saw the struggles of
poorer populations and the positive and
negative impacts of mechanization he
left the Navy and took an interest in
business and economics studying in a
University of Chicago Department
energized by the work of Milton fredman
and Friedrich Hayek through the 60s and
70s he noticed that the lives of the
most vulnerable people in the world were
improving and he did what virtually no
academic does now changed his mind just
like malus it's important to understand
the time in which Simon and erck kicked
off their debate when erck published the
population bomb in 1968 the world was
one generation removed from the most
terrible and destructive War it had ever
seen total military and civilian deaths
from World War II and its effects were
more than 80 million and the war ended
with the debut of the most terrifying
weapon ever created we'd spent the 20
years since worrying about which of the
two Global superpowers would use it on
the other meanwhile in the United States
social conflict drove riots in major
cities the last president had been
assassinated and in 68 both Martin
Luther King Jr and Bobby Kennedy were
killed right as dissatisfaction with the
Vietnam War was peing countries like
China and India were struggling to feed
bill Millions erck was in the same
situation as malus sitting in the
country with the world's highest
standard of living what reasonable
person would look at all that evidence
and conclude that you know what things
are actually pretty good
environmentalism had also branched out
from the simple conservation of the
Teddy Roosevelt era by the time Rachel
Carson published Silent Spring in 1962
which detailed threats from pesticides
used in agriculture including DDT a
radical movement was already happening
David Edenborough said that her book
changed the scientific world the most
behind only Darwin's Origin of Species
and it opened up the floodgates not only
on exposing problems in the environment
but rushing to fix them also in 1968
ecologist Garrett Harden published The
Tragedy of the commons which tapped the
metaphor of a public unregulated plot of
land used rationally by individuals to
the point of total obliteration Harden
wrote freedom in a Commons brings ruin
to all and the message was that left to
our own devices we were going to destroy
everything modifying human behavior is
hard the simplest solution was
restricting the ability to make humans
at all and if we didn't do it ourselves
nature would end up doing it for us in
the 1969 essay Eco catastrophe erck
wrote that the shape of the population
growth curve is one familiar to
biologists because like butterflies who
interact with and depend on their
environment populations swell and Shrink
based on what that environment can
provide he called it the outbreak crash
sequence in which populations rise in
times of abundant and crash or
completely disappear when that abundance
stops a year later he wrote an Autobon
that we've had most of the outbreak what
remains is mainly the crash the world
population at that time was 3.7 billion
and growing at a steady 2% per year
which put it on Pace to reach 7 billion
in 50 years malus had already outlined
two types of interventions to diffuse
What would eventually become erick's
population bomb preventative checks and
positive checks a preventative check is
an act that controls population by
reducing fertility rates deciding not to
have kids limiting the number of
children parents can have like China's
former one child policy and The Wider
availability of both contraception and
abortion a positive check is actually
not that positive it's something that
limits the human lifespan like War
disease famine or murder it can be an
active or passive depop and you might be
surprised at how many academics were
happy to meet out misery in the name of
ecojustice in their 1967 book famine
1975 Brothers William and Paul Paddock
proposed that the United States should
limit its foreign food Aid based on the
social behavior of countries with
growing populations they categorized
Egypt and India as can't be safe so no
food for them Pakistan scored higher the
paddocks thought they did deserve some
food and the idea to withhold food in an
effort to encourage or really punish
Behavior was typified by President
Lyndon Johnson's decision not to send
food Aid to India during the Bahar
Famine of 1966 he told an adviser I'm
not going to piss away foreign aid in
Nations where they refuse to deal with
their own population problems erck
supported food punishment he said I have
been citing paddock's work in all my
recent talks on the population crisis
and he called food punishment coercion
for a good cause because India was quote
hopeless it was India that actually
inspired erck to start thinking deeply
about the population bomb he had
traveled to Delhi in 1965 with his
family and what he saw was like a reboot
of London in the time of malus my wife
and daughter and I were returning to our
hotel in an ancient taxi the seats were
hopping with fleas the only functional
gear was third as we crawled through the
city we entered a crowded slum area the
temperature was well over 100 and the
air was a haze of dust and smoke the
streets seemed a live with people people
eating people watching people sleeping
people visiting arguing and screaming
people thrusting their hands through the
taxi window begging people defecating
and urinating people clinging to buses
people hurting animals people people
people people as we move slowly through
the mob hand horns squawking the dust
noise heat and cooking fires gave the
scene a hellish aspect early
knew something had to be done 65 years
ago Leonard Reed detailed the seemingly
impossible Global operation that led to
the creation of a single pencil think
about everything involved in production
growing and logging the cedar mining the
graphite truck drivers hauling it all
away and a guy in a lighthouse guiding
shipping vessels into Port it's millions
of people uniting on their own to make a
simple little thing and he had no IDE
idea the foundation for economic
education he created would turn his
unique perspective into YouTube videos
their unscene series investigates the
stories behind film television and pop
culture they just released a video about
how Disney cave to Chinese pressure to
suppress an incredible Martin Scorsese
film about the dolly llama and their
animated Common Sense soapbox Channel
reveals how the world really works you
can also check out invisible hands a
crash course in economics hosted by me
thanks to the foundation for economic
education for supporting this video
click the link to their YouTube channel
in the description below and if you can
handle unique analysis of complex
systems of human behavior throw them a
sub coercion wasn't off the table for
erck and his colleagues based on a
tenant that parents did not have a
natural right to have children in the
first place he toyed with a worldwide
limit of two children per set of of
parents Harden agreed saying the freedom
to breed is intolerable but warned that
we ought not say anything foolish about
coercion because trying to control
people by force would hurt the movement
in the population bomb erck said that
the government should take whatever
steps are necessary to establish a
reasonable population size in the United
States with a department of population
and environment that could fund Research
into Mass sterilizing agents forced
sterilization was an option for him and
so was introducing temporary infertility
agents in public drinking water he said
that Humanity will wake up one day to
find that compulsory birth control
offers the only hope of survival some of
his allies became increasingly nervous
about the implications of erick's more
radical ideas including members of the
group he founded called zero population
growth which still exists now called
population connection when they realized
that the targets of their Global
sterilization efforts were not going to
be well-educated well off white people
but Erick wasn't the only one sounding
the alarm on a grand scale 100
politicians diplomats economist and
Business Leaders had founded the club of
Rome in
1965 and their 1972 the limits to growth
a report for the club of Rome's project
on the predicament of mankind presented
an MIT computer model factoring in
population food production
industrialization pollution and
consumption of non-renewable natural
resources they called for an absolute
halt to economic growth warning that
without it industrial production would
would collapse population would suffer a
catastrophic Decline and the air sea and
land would be polluted Beyond Redemption
and the right time to intervene wasn't
today it was actually yesterday because
the collapse will not come gradually but
with awesome suddenness with no way of
stopping it the movement's most radical
ideas became reality in India as part of
a forced sterilization program in
1975 the BBC described the initiative
the drive to sterilize began in the
1970s when encouraged by loans amounting
to tens of millions of dollars from the
World Bank the Swedish International
Development Authority and the UN
population fund India embarked on an
ambitious population control program
during the 1975 emergency when civil
liberties were suspended Sanjay Gandhi
son of the former prime minister indiran
gandi began what was described by many
as a gruesome campaign to sterilize poor
men there were reports of police
cordoning off Villages and virtually
dragging the men to surgery
6.5 million Indian men were sterilized
in one year which was 15 times more than
the Nazis sterilized and about 2,000 of
those men died from Surgical complic
ations in the population bombs chapter
called what needs to be done Erick
writes when we suggested sterilizing all
Indian males with three or more children
he should have encouraged the Indian
government to go ahead with the plan we
the United States should have
volunteered logistic support in the form
of helicopters vehicles and surgical
instruments we should have sent doctors
to Aid in the program by setting up
centers for training paramedical
Personnel to do vasectomy
coercion perhaps but coercion in a good
cause his priority was to systemically
eliminate the world's fastest growing
populations which were almost
exclusively poor and nonwhite even in
his days of population concern Julian
Simon had a softer approach than erck or
the club of Rome he argued that avoiding
a birth cost a developing Nation about
$5 and that it would save
1114 which he called a fantastic bargain
and proposed offering payments to
families not to have children as a
mutually agreeable preventative check
his ideas rewarded people for their
choices instead of sterilizing them
against their will but Simon eventually
started to realize that people don't
work like butterflies when he studied
family Dynamics and their economic
rationalism he found that increased
income drove different behaviors among
families small families used additional
money to have larger families and larger
families didn't education levels had a
market effect on reproduction and still
do he looked to works from Simon cnit
and Richard easterland who concluded
that a larger population means more
creators and innovators and Esther
boer's work that showed population
density determines the type and scale of
agricultural production and its
efficiency Simon realized that
population growth was a lot more complex
than erck made it out to be and not
simply subject to the conceptual human
impact equation that erck created which
was impact equals population time
affluence time technology IAT
but Erick was the guy everyone wanted to
talk to he was young attractive and
highly charismatic which made him
totally unlike most academics he was
really funny and likable as he detailed
Humanity's impending doom which is why
he was a guest on The Tonight Show over
20 times here he is with Johnny Carson
talking about why he thinks the benefit
of a growing population just isn't
really there why don't we try doing a
really good job with four billion people
see if we can do that after we got four
billion people well taken care of and a
clean environment with good health
everybody's fed and everybody has
opportunities and so on then we can say
gee all right maybe we could do with
five what would be the advantage of five
well there would be another half a
billion women for instance which I would
find you like that yeah right but but uh
I just assume have the 4 billion taken
care of right first I think left yeah I
think you're right me sh Erick was
masterful at presenting the science of
demographics an environmental impact in
moral and emotional terms do you want
kids to starve well no do you want to
perpetuate human suffering no do you
want to see the destruction of Earth the
human race and all plant and animal life
I don't know probably not and he
fermented guilt too especially among
High consumption societies like the
United States and Western Europe is your
standard of living worth the price the
rest of the world pays in the BET Paul
Sabin writes that erick's brand of
rhetoric played a significant part in
whipping up Neo malthusian fervor he
points to a review of erick's 1970 book
population resources environment issues
and human ecology by Roger reville who
founded Harvard's Center for population
studies that highlights early use of
incendiary language staggering sobering
disaster three times enormously
drastically catastrophic dramatically
tremendous highly lethal extremely
dangerous twice especially virent more
severe extremely fortunate extremely
vulnerable almost total high potential
renewed Spectre not gruesome enough
colossal Hazard biological doomsday
super lethal and disastrously effective
Revel noted what he called apocalyptic
adverbs and adjectives because that list
I just read appeared in only four pages
out of a book of 300 Erick had become a
celebrity on TV was writing in Playboy
and Julian Simon was not happy the 70s
brought a series of energy crises
starting with the 1973 Oil Embargo that
resulted in a 43% increase in the price
of gas gas rationing in California based
on license plate numbers and serious
fears about dependence on fossil fuels
so Erick was looking pretty smart but
Simon insisted that population growth
and its Global problems should thrill
rather than frighten us how how could he
look at a world in crisis and possibly
think that Simon had spent the 70s
writing about all the reasons the erck
style doomsayers were were wrong wrong
about their models wrong about humans
and really just wrong about the way the
whole world works and he was writing
seemingly to no one in a 1997 interview
with wired titled the Doom Slayer he
said seeing erck tout such damaging
theories absolutely drove me out of my
skull here was a guy reaching a vast
audience leading this Juggernaut of
environmentalist Hysteria and I felt
utterly helpless what could I do go talk
to five people well the truth of the
matter is even those five people didn't
want to hear that between 1800 and 1980
the price of wheat in the United States
dropped precipitously despite the
population growing by about
4,500 it didn't matter that Simon found
that population did not actually
increase geometrically and birth rates
had even begun to fall in developed
countries including below replacement
rate which is the minimum number of
babies born to maintain current levels
of population in 1950 global life
expectancy was 45 by 1980 it was 61 and
that happened due to better medicine
better technology greater food
production and greater wealth that's
about a
35% longer life in 30 years all his
frustration led to an article that
brought Simon and his optimism into the
international debate over Humanity's
future in the June 27 1980 issue of
science Simon published resources
population environment and oversupply of
false bad news and the introductory
summary says it all false bad news about
population growth natural resources and
the environment is published widely in
the face of contradictory evidence for
example the world supply of arable land
has actually been increasing the
scarcity of Natural Resources including
food and energy has been decreasing and
basic measures of us Environmental
Quality show positive Trends the
aggregate data show no long run negative
effect of population growth upon
standard of living models that embody
forces omitted in the past especially
the influence of population size upon
productivity increase suggest a long run
positive effect of additional people
Simon completely decimated claims that
arable land had decreased worldwide
instead he noted that cultivated land
was rising at 1% per year he showed that
farmers in industrialized nations were
producing more food on less land as
population grew people were getting
better at farming and Technology was
making it cheaper and easier with fewer
people in evolve to the charge that the
world increasingly struggled with food
Simon showed that per capita food
production had also grown at about 1%
per year now it wasn't good news yay yay
yay cotton candy and sunshine all around
and it never will be Simon was honest
about that but he made the distinction
that the food problems in vulnerable
countries were overwhelmingly the result
of restricted markets war and political
instability he called out the New York
Times the United Nations the World Bank
and of course earling and he lamented
the Reliance on faulty computer models
that delivered grim and ultimately wrong
projections about our future he
concluded that population growth and
productivity increase are not
independent forces running a race
rather additional persons cause
technological advances by inventing
adapting and diffusing new productive
knowledge he also wasn't the first to
challenge malus and Derick on these
grounds and he had some unexpected
allies throughout history Carl Marx
called malus a plagiarist a sycophant
and a reverend Scribbler and angles
refuted malus's concept of Nature's
inevitable processes right writing that
the determining factor in history is the
production and reproduction of the
immediate Essentials of Life Marx and
angles saw the solution in a tightly
controlled collectivism that would
eventually become communism while Simon
pointed to the power of freedom and
markets but they all believe that the
way we organize Society can address
population problems that seem hopeless
but aren't
Economist Henry George stated the
difference most simply in his 1879
progress and poverty saying both the
jhawk and the man eat chickens but the
more j-hawks the fewer chickens while
the more men the more chickens monarch
butterflies eat nectar produced from
flowering plants if there's not enough
nectar to support the monarch butterfly
population some of them die until it
reaches a sustainable level but if
humans have restricted restricted access
to a particular resource like corn or
something or it becomes too expensive we
can just use something else Simon argued
that Humanity has two superpowers
adaptability and Innovation we can
invent we can improve and we can
substitute all of which constitute less
of a threat to resources than earlick
thought because to Simon those finite
resources aren't nearly as finite as
they seem he used copper as an example
saying that we can't calculate future
quantities of copper because new loads
new methods of mining copper and
variations in grades of copper loads
because copper can be made from other
metals and because of the vagueness of
the boundaries within which copper might
be found including the sea and other
planets and even less possible is a
reasonable calculation of the amount of
future Services of the sort we are now
ACC customed to get from copper because
of recycling and because of the
substitution of other materials for
copper as in the case of the
communication satellite translation we
are good at finding more we're getting
more efficient at extracting it we're
using it more smartly and how we use it
now doesn't have any bearing on how
we'll use it in the future if we use it
at all Simon wrote in science that we
have so much bad news about the world
because that's where the funding is for
researchers and that late night talk
shows don't have guests who talk about
everything getting better but he also
said that the cumulative nature of
exponential growth models have the power
to seduce and be witch especially
because so many people compare the
present with the potential future
idealized or awful instead of comparing
the present to the Past Simon and his
growing rank of optimists were derided
as adhering to cornucopian ISM
referencing the Greek mythological Horn
of abundance that produced food and
never ran out erck said Simon was like
the guy who jumps off the Empire State
Building and says how great things are
going so far as he passes the 10th floor
berick insisted that not only did we
have finite resources but that we were
using them up fast while Simon was
effectively arguing that sources were
endless and it didn't help that he wrote
that Humanity's only real limit was the
theoretical total weight of the universe
to Erick we were doomed to Simon humans
not only had the capacity to address our
problems but that we'd come out even
better than before we had them it was
kind of a big difference so the battle
lines had been finally drawn it was time
to make a wager on the the future of the
human race it was time for the BET in
social science quarterly Simon said he'd
like to take that bet with erck about
England still existing 20 years on but
instead he proposed to stake
$10,000 on my belief that the cost of
non-government controlled raw materials
including grain and oil will not rise in
the long run Simon said that erck could
choose any five raw materials he wanted
Simon left it up to him and that they
would track the prices of each commodity
over the course of 10 years on September
29th 1980 Erick agreed to a reduced
wager of
$1,000 putting 200 bucks into each of
five resources he and his colleagues had
predicted would rise in price over the
coming decade copper chromium nickel tin
and tungsten if the inflation adjusted
prices went up Simon would pay erck
their different in values between 1980
and 1990 if their prices went down Simon
would win the bet and erck would pay the
difference copper has been used in
various capacities for over 10,000 years
from primitive tools to Modern
conductors chromium is a component to
stainless steel and it's why your Dez
wrenches are hard and don't rust nickel
is one of four ferromagnetic elements we
use it now in the rechargeable batteries
of electric vehicles tin is important
for Alloys and plating which is why
plated steel cans were referred to as
tin cans tungsten is extremely hard and
dense and it's necessary in x-ray tubes
and Welding these five materials
presented a cross-section of nature
dependent human activity that erck was
convinced would force demand and
scarcity to collide the 1980s saw a
dramatic policy shift in the United
States under Ronald Reagan who advocated
for a Freer Market in line with Simon 's
optimism fears about endangered species
became real holes in the ozone layer
threatened to increase exposure to ultra
violet radiation and the Exxon BD oil
spill dominated the news at the end of
the decade the threat of nuclear war
still loomed and a nuclear disaster in
Chernobyl came 7 years after 3 Mile
Island so things did not seem awesome
but on September 29th 1990 it was time
for someone to pay up in 1980 the price
of chromium was
$3.90 per pound in 1990 it was
$370 tin dropped by half from
$872 to
$388 three of the five Metals had gone
down in price despite inflation and the
other two both fell in inflation
adjusted terms Simon won the bets on all
five of The Chosen medals but more
importantly to him Erick and his
doomsday philosophy lost in October of
1990 a check from Wells Fargo Bank in
the amount of
$576 and7 cents arrived in Julian
Simon's mailbox there was no note and
the check was signed by Ann Erick Paul's
wife in his book The Ultimate resource
Julian Simon wrote adding more people
causes problems but people are also the
means to solve these problems the main
fuel to speed the world's progress is
our stock of knowledge the breaks are
our lack of imagination and unsound
social regulations of these activities
the ultimate resource is people
especially skilled spirited and hopeful
young people endowed with Liberty who
will exert their wills and imaginations
for their own own benefits and so
inevitably will they benefit the rest of
us as well it was truly a Triumph of
Hope and optimism over Doom and Gloom or
did juli and Simon just get lucky a 2009
paper called luck or skill an
examination of the erck Simon bet
reveals that had the BET been run one
more time from 1990 to 2000 Simon would
have triumphed again but had the wager
taken place for of the possible 98
10-year periods between 1900 and 2007
Erick would have won
61.2% of the time so maybe Erick was
right
nah actually the data shows a massive
crash in commodities prices following
World War I which means they spent the
rest of the century slowly Rising back
to their former levels creating an
artificial I bias towards er's Rising
prices Theory and proving Simon's exact
point about the power of human
cooperation or in the case of a World
War the lack of cooperation to determine
how we use and value resources it's
really easy to look at the results of
the ERX Simon wager and scoff at the
loser and it's even easier to revisit
failed doomsday predictions of a
disappearing England and worldwide in
killing billions and laugh at how wrong
it all was it's much harder to
understand why those predictions happen
in the first place and why it's
completely natural to think everything
is bad and getting worse it's why the
doomsayers are so seductive and popular
and why the doomed Slayers aren't just
ignored they are hated in in 2016
Swedish physician Hans rosling was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer he
began writing factfulness 10 reasons
were wrong about the world as what he
called his last battle in my lifelong
mission to fight devastating ignorance
it was published in 2018 a year after he
died rosling detailed 10 human instincts
that conspire to convince us that the
world is forever going in the wrong
direction which can inform devastatingly
wrong reactions to our problems the
first is the gap instinct which is to
consider the differences between the top
and the bottom rather than focusing on
the majority or whether all levels of
society are improving in spite of
relative differences and he argues that
our negative Instinct programs us not to
bother noticing improvements at all
our straight line Instinct causes us to
assume that our current trends will
continue exactly as they are right now
rather than accelerating or decelerating
and our fear Instinct distorts our
perception of risk to make us overvalue
possible negatives our size Instinct
makes us feel overwhelmed by the sheer
scale of a problem as our generalization
Instinct lumps all our problem problems
together as being equally threatening
and our destiny Instinct makes us feel
like none of our problems ever get
solved even though they tends to get
better slowly our single perspective
Instinct hyper focuses on just one
possible solution rather than
considering many solutions that work in
combination and our blame Instinct makes
us focus on the bad guys who we're
convinced are responsible for the
problem but the most threatening might
be the urgency instinct which drives us
to feel that there's an impending
catastrophe if we don't do something
immediately rather than one step at a
time only a single comma separates do
something stupid from do something
stupid Erick may have been 0 for five on
his bet with Julian Simon but he's 10
for 10 on rosling's checklist of
instinctual
pathologies Paul erck is now in his '90s
and he's vibrant energetic and still
insisting that he's right or that he was
never really that wrong in January of
this year erck tweeted after being
featured on 60 Minutes that if I'm
always wrong so is science since my work
is always peer-reviewed including the
population bomb and I've gotten
virtually every scientific honor sure
I've made some mistakes but no basic
ones Elon Musk disagreed in June he said
Paul erck has done immense damage to
humanity immense I despise him in April
of 2023 erck gave an interview at
Stanford in which he said he wouldn't
deny anyone the opportunity to have
children but that if you have 10
children you're an evil person
trying to basically destroy the world
the birth rate in Somalia is 7.5 times
higher than in South Korea but it isn't
clear whether Erick thinks Somalians are
7.5 times more evil in 1981 the year
after the erck Simon wager and the year
in which Simon's the ultimate resource
came out 88% of the population of China
lived in extreme poverty Ping's Market
reforms then fueled tremendous economic
growth and an increased standard of
living China's extreme poverty rate
today is under
1% there are no longer any restrictions
on reproduction and China has more
billionaires than any country in the
world in 1980 the average daily caloric
intake globally was
2487 today it's 2
928 in India it Rose from
1,994 50 years ago to
2,533 today and in a long list of
countries we now have a new problem of
consuming too many calories life
expectancy globally was just 61 years in
1980 today it's about
73 in 2022 about 630,000 people world
wide died from AIDS related illnesses
down
69% from about 2 million per year just
20 years ago and you'll Now find TV
commercials for competing combination
anti-retroviral drugs that reduced the
HIV virus to undetectable
levels in 1998 Julian Simon was jumping
rope on his deck the phone rang and his
wife went upstairs to answer it it was
their daughter Judith with news that she
was pregnant with Julian's first
grandchild a grandchild that was not
just one more mouth to feed but another
human with potentially unlimited
creative capacity a brand new human mind
added on to the six billion of the time
one with the power to innovate to
identify new problems and to solve the
old ones or maybe just one more human to
make life worth living not an insect
whose primitive cerebral ganglia draws
it into a flame to its own death but a
person who can harness that flame to
cook Heat their houses and smelt ore
from the Rocks they dig up Julian
Simon's grandchild would be one more
soul in a world that he knew got a
little better every day even when it
didn't feel that way Julian's wife ran
down the stairs to give him the great
news she found him dead on the living
room floor he'd had a heart attack at
65 Paul erick's population bomb theory
was right about
butterflies since his 1980 bet with
Simon the Western monarch butterfly has
seen a PO population reduction of over
95% we cleared forests for farming and
the milkweed that monarchs feed on
flourished herbicides to control weeds
in crops shrunk available milkweed and
Butterfly populations were
devastated but we've responded by doing
exactly what Simon said we would
creating a rehabilitation plan that
includes planting 1.3 billion milkweed
stems through the central migratory
Flyway everyone knows we are mired in
problems and the consequences of our
progress but the one way to avoid
Armageddon is to think beyond the Doom
to resist the siren song of our most
Basic Instincts and to make use of our
one Tim ultimate finite
[Music]
resource
you and as
always thanks for
[Music]
watching because it has been agreed by
the nations of the world that the Earth
can no longer sustain a continuously
increasing population
childbearing is here with
forbidden